a un tropiezo de distancia
cuáles son las preguntas
y cómo ser feliz en la vida pero la
verdadera pregunta aquí
y también quiero agradecerles a esas
personas que se quedaron así
porque el primer paso para alcanzar la
felicidad también hicieron esto consigo
mismo y a veces pues no se sabe
y quiero que sepan algo
para los que levantaron la mano el
concepto que tienes tú tú y aquel chico
de hasta atrás es bien diferente
para algunos felicidad es obtener un
trabajo para otros es que te vaya bien
en un examen y de hecho durante estos
días que sabía que iba a venir acá te le
pregunté a una adolescente elige y tú
para ti que es felicidad
para mi felicidad es que me conteste un
mensaje en la chica que me gusta
y te contesto
visto y bueno esperemos más adelante si
le contesten seguir caminando y esa es
mexicalli su calor
vi a un adulto y le pregunté oye para ti
que es felicidad y se para mi felicidad
es llegar a casa después de un día largo
de trabajo
y le sonó el celular mal
cassano entonces es importante que desde
ahorita desde que estamos iniciando
estas charlas sepamos qué felicidad es
un concepto diferente para cada uno de
nosotros vamos y con eso
por qué
yo les quiero platicar lo que para mí es
felicidad
si pregunta en este momento felicidad
para mí es este momento estando acá
frente a ustedes
que no me las creo y si le preguntan de
ellos elisa de 8 años
se le pregunta de alice dos años su
felicidad de laborar yo sólo quería
hablar me encantaba contar historias y
ver la reacción de la gente hacia un
nuevo me encantaba yo podía hablar de
24/7 así
todo el día puede estar hablando
y ahí justo ahí me topo con mi primer
tropiezo
a todas las personas les gusta escuchar
y tiene que ver con dos grandes
dificultades que yo tenía en ese momento
cumplir los ocho años yo deseaba como
carlitos de los rubros para aquellos
primeros rurales yo deseaba y aparte
tenía una forma de hablar super super
mega hiper rápida que mejor que me
aparato fue un articulador no se daba
abasto
a contar todas las historias
y para las personas será complicado no
imagina tratar de escuchar a una niña
que deseaba y que hablaba rap y durante
10 minutos
lo que yo escuchaba era esto ya que a
tener es una obra que ya basta
y a lo mejor no suena
pero para aquellos que levantaron la
mano y que hicieron a mí me hace felices
imagínate tener alguien que te dicen lo
me gustaba hablar y aparte que se hacía
esta producción
me llevo al dentista y me coloco un
retenedor que funciona como atrapa
lenguas y aparte antes de desayunar me
hacía leer un cuentito corto para yo
poder respetar los espacios
y después de un par de meses
digo no toda la gente
me sentía
igual esto que realmente me hace feliz
lo estoy pudiendo hacer y estate
pero imagínense unas historias así de
niño de 8 años
fíjate queriendo estar when you´re 6to
y yo creo que
en 20 años más
ustedes
y la sonrisa
no solo con el tiempo sino con las
experiencias hace un momento lo decía mi
compañera esperamos que se después de
que salgas diferente
porque todo esto
lamentablemente hemos vivido en una
sociedad que nos enseña que a todos nos
tiene que hacer feliz
o nos tiene que gustar lo mismo si eres
niños que tienen que gustar las
soluciones ninja tiene que gustar
y lo cierto es que no
[Música]
cinco años
estamos en una relación que hace cinco
años nos hacía feliz
date la oportunidad de en
esta parte
y les quiero regalar un concepto
psicológico bien importante
y esto es diferenciar lo que tú eres de
lo que tú haces
porque como sociedad también hemos
aprendido que si te equivocas ya valió
ya quédate ahí está en cada una
y si estamos hablando de que la
felicidad está un tropiezo a distancia
quiere decir que un tropiezo nos acerca
más a la felicidad
y aquí me encanta recordar una historia
de un chico que vino a mi oficina hace
un par de meses llegó así tiró la
mochila y sé
profe de problema temáticas otra vez
pero sabe que no me sorprende porque
siempre ha sido malo en matemáticas solo
que pues ya me comienza a preocupar
porque pues me quisiera graduar
está bien sexto semestre yo ok pero me
hubiera gustado que hubiera la seguridad
con la que se dijo a sí mismo que era
malo en mate pésimo en matemáticas según
él
su definición entonces ahí me permite
decirle lo siguiente sabes que pablito
ruiz cuando naciste no es como que el
doctor te recibiera dijeran es niño pesó
3 kilos 700 gramos 50 centímetros de
largo
malo en matemáticas por lo con los malos
matemáticas no a menos y mi idea que un
doctor lo contrario no pero no no pasa
eso no sirve no pasa eso que uno nace si
mueres siendo malo en algo lo que pasa
es que nos hemos colocado etiquetas de
swing malo en matemáticas soy torpe me
viera y digitel as dejas no
y no es una risita de cuidado
y hay que tener cuidado con eso porque
una etiqueta no necesariamente o no
tendría por qué quedarse ahí
y cuando le dije esto el chico me dijo
sé que no nací malo en mante por frei y
yo no sólo lo que has tenido un montón
de acciones que no te han ayudado a ser
bueno en matemáticas hay entonces que
aunque a pues le dio una serie de
estrategias y al par de meses mejoró
mucho su rendimiento académico en esa
materia y él se sorprendió y me acuerdo
que es la primera vez que volvió a ser
un examen de mates regresó y proceso y
bueno en mate y yo
te dije etiquetas y aprendí una lección
que no sé qué pero sobre todo a mí lo
que más me gustó de todo esto no es que
le fuera bien en matemáticas o sea que
bueno no se graduó pero si no quiere
aprender a los 17
que la forma en como él se define a sí
mismo es lo más vital
si alguien te ha colocado una etiqueta
que no te pertenece hoy es un buen día
para que te la quites porque no va
contigo
o si te has dejado a ti mismo una
etiqueta que no te pertenece quita terán
o yo recuerdo que ya tenía hace unos
años una etiqueta pero bien presente
tenerla enojona porque me dijeron que
era no lo cree y cada pequeña molestia
y cuando aprendía esto dije que no toca
reaccionar a 5 y lo cambie
y yo creo que fácilmente unos seis años
sin tener una molestia gigantesca dijo
el poder de las etiquetas
y si usted no pueden aprender hoy
estaría increíble
ahora
esta es la transformación del chico lo
hizo muy feliz y les decía finalmente en
donde queremos todos
yo no alguien que me diga que no quiere
ser feliz aquí
tenemos a la siguiente todos queremos
ser feliz y lo cierto es que para tu ser
feliz se tienes que tropezar a fuerzas
te vas a tropezar quisiera decirte que
no quisiera lo mejor colocarte en una
burbuja como lo hace tu mamá pero no te
vas a tropezar y para que para que tú
puedas ver si esto es lo tuyo si vale la
pena y te apasiona porque qué flojera
estar viviendo una vida que no te
apasiona que no te quiero de la sangre
que no te mueve para eso sin poder
tropezarte para que una vez que llegues
ese error digas sabes que siempre nos
por aquí mejor me muevo o digas sabes
que no me importa me equivoqué pero le
voy a
y te das cuenta y valoras realmente lo
que está ocurriendo con tu vida para eso
sirven los tropiezos hay una frase que
me encanta y dice es fallado una vez
tras otra en mi vida y es por eso que
triunfado con lo dije yo son palabras
que nos regala michael jordan y él tuvo
una serie de trucos
generalmente sabemos todas las victorias
yo no lo recordamos y brincando a lo
largo
pero él al igual que muchos también tuvo
tropiezos de otros personajes
importantes que se tropezaron fue steve
jobs steven spielberg y hasta los virus
que todos gustan tuvieron tropiezos y el
principal tropiezo para ellos fue la
crítica y el rechazo
quisiera que levantara las manos si
alguno de ustedes alguna vez los han
criticado o rechazado
ay qué bien
yo sé que no se miran pero fueron todos
entonces ustedes ya saben si estás en el
cafecito y quieres hablar
fíjate que tengo algo en común con steve
jobs rechazó criticar eso
y la diferencia entre sus grandes
personajes y nosotros
es que ellos no se dejaron definir por
eso
ellos dijeron ah estás diciendo que soy
malo en esto fíjate cómo lo hago y no
necesariamente para el resto de la gente
sino para sí mismos para demostrarse que
sí se pueden como yo no te han ocho años
que pasaban callando - es una rata ya te
hartas
y que me vean aquí si lo hice
pero pude haber sido una persona que se
dejará definir por el rechazo o que se
dejará tener por la crítica y no lo hice
y ahí está la clave la gran la gran
clave de todo esto es saber quién eres
porque si yo sé quién soy entonces quién
me está definiendo yo y si alguien me
ofende o me dice algo quién no está en
mí dice de mí en mi definición creen que
me la voy a creer
creo que me voy a molestar no porque no
es mi definición ahora no soy perfecta
no soy perfecta y habrá cosas que me dio
dios y cierto tienen razón aquí me
equivoqué tengo que hacerlo o tienes
razón aquí volvió hablar muy rápido
tengo que calmarme
pero son cosas que yo voy a filtrar
no sé si ustedes les han comentado que
los adolescentes siempre se los digo a
mis estudiantes para que no se sientan
mal están viviendo un momento neuro
anatómicamente especial y ellos si tú
les dices una palabra digamos no muy
saludable espera bien duro porque es
como en la adolescencia están
aprendiendo a definir para ello lo que
tú le digas es bien fuerte ya sea que
los levantes o que los tires con una
palabra porque apenas están definiendo
pero nosotros como adultos jóvenes
adultos
se supone que ya tenemos una definición
clara ción
tenemos una definición y si alguien me
llegue me dice algo que no siento que va
conmigo respeto opiniones diferentes
pero hasta en a menos que sepa que eso
me va a ayudar a crecer por primera
invitación también aquí es yo soy que
tenga un cuadernito bien bonito más
adelante en una de las charlas date la
oportunidad de poder escribir quién eres
hoy 22 de junio porque puedo asegurarte
quien no es la misma persona que hace
cinco años y que no quieres lo mismo y
si eres de las pocas personas que sigue
queriendo lo mismo desde hace cinco años
quiero invitarte a que cambiar las
soluciones porque no te están dando un
resultado si a veces vivimos pensando a
es que ya lo intenté todo no pero
intentas en muchas formas de lo mismo
entonces intenta algo diferente y sé que
suena bien fácil cómoda intenta algo
diferente y si necesitas ayuda para eso
busca ayuda con familiares amigos o si
es necesario con terapia no pasa nada
canasta básica huevos test y terapia no
averiado y perón
puedo decirte que no sigo y no te voy a
ofrecer 277 millones de respuestas en
punto 7 segundos
bueno punto 4 de ellos
surgir lista gonzález una persona al
igual que tú
y voy a decirte qué felicidad es lo que
quieras que sea y que está bien siempre
y cuando no afecte terceros y que vale
la pena luchar por eso y vale la pena
tropezarte para que te des cuenta si
vale la pena siendo tuyo y si te
apasiona y quiero darte un truco más
porque a veces también los tropiezos que
tenemos se pueden convertir en un ciclo
vicioso al sabotaje y de verdad que no
me gustaría que después de esta charla
se te convirtiera algo en un ciclo
vicioso y para eso te voy a mostrar los
tres elementos del ciclo vicioso para
que se pase un tropiezo ya se está
convirtiendo en uno de esos el primero
es el miedo a fracasar el miedo a que no
te salgan bien las cosas a no poder
realizar el sueño si estás en esa fase
ok es la primera pero esta primera fase
te va a llevar a un autosabotaje a tener
excusas a estar presionando o hasta
autolesión arte y con autolesión o me
refiero a que te cortes me refiero a que
te sea votes con alimentación con sus
estilos de hábitos
y si estás en autosabotaje es lo que
sigue es una invalidación como la del
chico que era malo en mate que él se
juraba que era malo en matemáticas y
solamente era una etiqueta que se haya
puesto o que a lo mejor alguien más se
la puso lamentablemente fíjate si estás
en alguna de esas zonas y el escudo para
ni siquiera pasar por ahí claramente
saber quién eres así que te vuelvo a
invitar a que escribas tu definición en
el día de hoy y que tengas en cuenta lo
siguiente que para que un tropiezo no se
convierte en un ciclo vicioso es
importante definir cuál es tu felicidad
el día de hoy saber quién eres saber
para ti qué es felicidad y también
identificar si estás en una de esas
zonas de tropiezos o de ciclos viciosos
para que entonces jamás en tu vida
jamás un tropiezo se convierta en un
ciclo vicioso del sabotaje
y si en el caso de que después de
estallar todavía te vuelvas a tropezar
descuida que la felicidad está en
tropiezo de distancia muchas gracias
[Aplausos]